-I'm happy to see you in person.
I think the last time we talked,
you were 10 days away
from having
your third grandchild.
-That's right.
That's right.
That's how we time
how long it's been.
It was in the middle of 2020.
My beautiful
little granddaughter, Una,
my third grandchild -- she was
born just before July 4, 2020.
And I was on the show with you.
-It's been two years already?
-Yeah.
-It goes by kind of fast,
doesn't it?
-Wonderful.
And that dark year,
she was the little bright star.
-Yeah.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
You must be -- come on.
You must be the most fun grandpa
in the world, or Papa?
What do they call you?
-She calls me Papa.
She's just as delightful for me
as I am for her, far more.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I know, yeah.
But, yeah, you're artistic.
You paint.
-Well, I also
entertain children.
You know, I've been on your show
doing kid songs.
-That's right.
Do you have any new songs
that you sing to her
that she likes?
-Well, she has a favorite.
She's already
picking her favorites.
She's always asked
for the "Bee Song,"
which is a song
my father sang to me
and his mother sang to him.
So I guess it's been around
a long time.
-I don't know the "Bee Song."
-I will --
I'll sing it for you, Jimmy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But to really appreciate
the impact of this song,
you have to pretend
that you're all 2 years old.
[ Laughter ]
♪ oh, I wish I were
a rhinocenario ♪
♪ Hippopatamie,
aha-ha-ha-ha ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ But since I'm not
and never can hope to be ♪
♪ Hippopotamius,
rhinocenarie ♪
♪ I'm a June bug ♪
♪ I'm a bumblebee ♪
♪ I buzz and hit my head
against the tree ♪
♪ Aha-ha-ha-ha ♪
[ Laughter ]
There we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, you know how to do it.
-She absolutely loves this song.
-I love that song, too.
I love that.
-You can see why I get
this requested constantly.
-Yeah.
You are a great --
I mean,
you do entertain children.
Do you still do that
or go out there and --
-Yeah, well,
I'm sort of reviving it
now again
with a little baby nearby.
I do kid songs, and I'm famous
for my animal sounds.
-Oh.
What animal sounds?
-The song, "I Had a Rooster."
Don't worry. I'm not gonna
sing another song.
[ Laughter ]
But you run through
all the barnyard animals
and make their noises.
And among little,
little children,
I'm very famous for that.
The cow goes, "Mooooooo."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's an advanced cow.
-Yeah.
And the horse goes --
[ Whinnies ]
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, that's what you want.
That's what you want
right there.
-I've been trying to figure out
where to work that in
to serious drama.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
Talk to me. Next script,
I'll work it in somehow.
I want to go through a few of
your roles just off the top --
I made a little list of things.
You played a prime minister --
you were Churchill.
You played a president --
"Hillary and Clinton."
A reverend in "Footloose."
A serial killer, "Dexter" --
by the way, unbelievable.
A scientist,
"Manhattan Project."
A painter, "Love is Strange."
And an alien,
"Third Rock from the Sun."
I was asking,
do people ever go up to you and,
like, not talk to you
like you're John Lithgow
and go like,
"Oh, you're Winston Churchill,"
or, "You're..."
-Not really.
Actually, when I play
a really bad character,
like the Trinity Killer,
or, you know, my villains,
they tend to shy away from me.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, I was in --
I played a horrifying character,
a psychopathic character
in Brian de Palma's "Blow Out"
in the '80s.
-Oh, yeah.
-And the weekend it opened
in New York,
I was living
on the Upper West Side.
The garbage bin
in my apartment building
was just opposite
the service elevator.
And everybody always used
the service elevator,
since it was so much faster than
the usual -- the regular one.
-Sure.
-So, just as I was emptying
the garbage, the service
elevator door opened behind me.
I turned around.
There was a woman who lived on
the same floor,
although I'd never
seen her before, nor she me.
She saw me and turned white, and
practically had a heart attack.
[ Laughter ]
"Aaah!"
She had just been
to see "Blow Out,"
and there I was at about 9:30 --
[ Laughter ]
-By a dumpster.
By a dumpster.
-And I went to her like,
"Oh!"
I only made it worse!
-You're making it worse!
"Calm down, calm down."
-It's an occupational hazard.
[ Laughter ]
This happens from time to time.
-Let's talk about "The Old Man"
because I'm very excited
about this.
You know, we love Jeff Bridges
here on our show, as well.
And I know this kind of got --
it got pushed.
There was all sorts of problems,
and different things
that came down.
But, finally, it's finished.
-It's finished.
It opens -- actually, it's
on tonight for the first time.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And it's really, really good.
This show started
2 1/2 years ago.
-Yeah.
-And we got about
2 1/2 months of it done.
We finished about four episodes.
Then came COVID.
And about eight months passed.
We were just about
ready to start again.
Then came
poor Jeff's cancer diagnosis.
-Yes.
-And that took
another 10 months.
He went through hell with it.
He recovered.
He has survived.
He's better.
-Yes!
-He's better than ever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Exactly right.
-It's wonderful.
-Have you guys
worked together before?
-We had never
worked together before.
We'd barely even met before.
And for those --
that long 18-month stretch,
I had never acted with him yet
because it's,
in the nature of the series,
that our two characters
are sort of kept apart
but drawn together over
the course of seven episodes.
And we hadn't gotten to them
getting together yet.
So, finally, February and March
of this year,
I got to act with Jeff Bridges
and found him to be the --
as everybody would expect,
the most wonderful man
and a terrific acting partner.
This show starts great tonight.
But just wait
for the seventh episode.
It just gets better and better.
It's as extraordinary thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is there any way to set it up,
this show?
-Well, we -- we play two guys,
who, 30 years ago,
in Afghanistan,
during the Soviet war,
not the American
involvement there,
they were operatives in the CIA.
I was sort of his handler,
and he was a kind of renegade
who did some of the --
some very bad things
for very good reasons,
and it all blew up.
And we were forced
to stay apart
and sort of not even acknowledge
each other for 30 years.
And that event
comes back to haunt us
and, as I say, pulls us back.
We have to engage.
And we play this long
cat-and-mouse game
of international intrigue.
But it's so -- it's so fine.
I saw it up
on a big screen at our --
the other night,
and it's as good as any movie.
It's wonderful.
-Oh, I love that.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's John Lithgow
in "The Old Man."
Take a look at this.
-He's on the move.
-Yeah, I can see that.
-Just minutes before
we arrived on target, too.
-That's unfortunate.
-You were just on the phone
out there, yeah?
-Yes, I was.
-May I ask who it was
you were talking to?
-No, you may not.
Son, do you know what
my position is at the FBI?
-Yes, sir.
-Do you think I was appointed
to that position
because I'm somebody
that's safe to [bleep] with?
-No, sir.
-Then quit staring at me
before I start getting the idea
I'm being [bleep] with.
-Yeah, that's exactly right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What's up?!
Yes!
John Lithgow!
Check out new episodes
of "The Old Man"
every Thursday on FX
and on Hulu the next day.
We'll be right back
with Noah Schnapp.
Stick around, everybody.